- The cop car was because of a sex thing.
We're getting so dark, this is BuzzFeed,
this is for families.
(sultry saxophone music)
Hi, my name is Anita Procedure.
- And I'm Roz Drezfalez.
- And I'm Pickle.
- I think there's a lot I
don't know about these two,
I think there's some
dark corridors of secrets
that I'm about to find out.
- I feel like I know a
lot, but this is fun, too.
- I think I already know too much.
- I'm excited to see what secrets
I'm gonna use against them.
I mean,
- Blackmail.
- We're gonna have fun.
(upbeat club music)
- With family?
- It was Easter.
- Easter?
- An Easter gathering,
I came home in drag,
just to get footage of my
Dad and I loving one another
for an audition.
I was like, "Look, my family loves me.
Cut. Okay, I'm leaving."
- That's a very specific experience
that really fit the question--
- Really, yeah.
- Does anyone win this game?
(string quartet pizzicato)
- Honey, no.
- No.
- Okay, define sex.
- Why don't you define sex,
since the answer's obviously yas.
- Um, Okay.
So, I've never had sex, sex,
but I have gone down on someone
in a club bathroom while
looking like a 90's prostitute.
- [Pickle] Oh, that doesn't count.
- Oh wait, we know who
she (bleep) in a bathroom.
- No, you don't.
- Yeah, we do.
Don't make me say the name.
- Wait, we do? I don't.
- No, you don't.
- I do.
- Oh, you told us.
- I'm in on this.
- Oh, maybe it was somebody else.
- It might have happened multiple times.
Well, moving on, next question?
(jazzy saxophone music)
- Oh.
- Oh, honey, this is all natural.
- No.
- I don't know, guys, what do you think?
- Have you?
- What do you think I've gotten done?
- Cheeks.
- Cheeks?
- I don't know, whatever
it was, it wasn't enough.
- Maybe Botox?
Wait, how old are you, like, 40?
- What?
- Seventeen.
No, I haven't.
- You haven't.
- I just wanted to see what you would say.
- Yeah, I was gonna say, whatever
you got, it wasn't enough.
(bright guitar music)
- Oh, sweetie.
- Yas.
Finally one that I can relate to.
- I can confidently say--
- It's not drag if you don't fall.
- It happens all the time, I don't know
how to walk in heels.
I skipped that part of the drag seminar,
and so now I don't know
how to walk in heels,
so I fall all the time.
- I was having a moment, and
I just went (whoosh noise).
Timber.
- Holy shit.
- I started the verse, I
come walking down the stairs,
and I fuckin' (whoosh noise),
in a gown, looking gorgeous,
lip-syncing already to a pop song,
and I was just done.
Hashtag done.
- You just have to own it, though.
- Oh, I did, I got right the fuck back up
and got that lip-sync on point.
(jazzy bass music)
What do you think we're
doing after this, my god.
- How do you think we met?
- [Camera Man] Foursome?
- Where do you draw that line?
If they're participating,
or they're just--
- Watching.
- Holding a camera.
- [Camera Man] Participating.
- Yeah. Yes, foursome.
- Four.
- Fivesome?
- Yes.
- Keep goin'.
- Sixsome?
- Three, four, five
definitely that I can recall.
- Six or seven, but I could've
done without two of them.
I would've made some cuts.
- The casting process was a little loose.
- But the boy in the middle
was so cute, that it was like,
"I'm not gonna be petty about this."
(upbeat club music)
- Are you kidding me?
- Well, what does that--
- Well, not intentionally
- No.
- but yes, because things
end up in your bag--
- I mean, yeah.
- And then you're like,
"This is a nice product. I
guess I'll have to keep it."
- Does it count as stealing if you
take something from them
without them knowing,
and then you use it in
your wardrobe regularly?
- That's what stealing is,
so just turn that around.
- I'm kidding, no, I haven't
really, you haven't intention--
- No, you end up with things, though,
and then you intentionally
don't give it back.
I feel like we all grew
together as a group,
what d'you guys think?
- Spiritually and emotionally.
- Did I win?
(upbeat club music)